the padres are so glad to be home and
the friendly convines of petco park they
took the first two in texas looking to
take the next two here in the home and
home series between the texas rangers
and the san diego padres
chris paddock the 24 year old making his
sixth start
and when you look at chris yeah he's
been kind of struggling lately the last
eight plus innings he's given a five
home runs for chris paddock very unlike
chris paddock now one on willie calhoun
makes his first appearance of the series
i think he went and home played umpire
alfonso marquez agrees strikeout number
one for chris paddock two down here in
the first inning
those are the swings you like to see
when chris paddock is on the mound two
down here in the first inning santana at
first base and here is joey gallo
and a swing and a miss uses it to strike
out joey gallo back to back k's padres
are coming up lance lynn is on the mound
for the texas rangers 33 years old
making his sixth start this guy was
fifth in cyan award voting last year it
should be very fun to see how
lin
handles tatis jr
well len gets the better of him in their
first head-to-head a strikeout for the
second out of the inning
machado
28 yeah yeah okay and he's out and he
strikes out here and lynn
punches out todd jr and manny machado
paddock with a big curveball to adore
for a strike tries another one and
rookie hits this one a mile out to right
it's gone
wow there was a lot of fun things that
just went on right there for rugby
o'dour who just hit
his third home run
of the season eric hosmer will lead it
off for the padres
that good swing and a miss and hosmer
strikes out that's three straight punch
outs for lance lynn not wasting a lot of
time either lance lynn rangers will
shift three guys on the right side of
the infield against pro far switch
hitter batting left-handed
in the second inning this one is out
towards left center field and deep back
it goes towards the oh and it's gone
jerks and profile it's his fourth home
run of the year the former texas ranger
has tied this game one to one
lead off home run here in the third
inning ties the game and that one's
right down the middle and profar
stays on it squares it up and sends it
on its way breaks up fernando tatis jr
fly ball center field nick solak going
back nick zolac at the wall mcsolach
will watch it go
fernando tatis jr home run number 12 of
the year he'll add to his major league
leading total
they'll take it out of this yard too
it's 2-1 padres
oh a little cut fastball maybe a slider
out in front takes it to el centro a lot
of the kids are having some fun tonight
so two down odor head first on the bunch
single nick solac is the batter
swing and a miss and paddock picks up
strikeout number five three and a half
done 2-1 padres willie calhoun the
number three hitter
runners are going at least the runner
from second to third throw to third is
in time caught stealing
austin hedges throws out connor falefa
third base nicely done
three two strike three call over the
outside corner that one came back nicely
beautiful pitch by lance lynn for
strikeout number five fernando tatis jr
third played appearance against lance
lynn
on the ground up the middle into center
field a base hit for tati says grisham
is headed to third throws going there
but it's not a good throw and he is in
safely
nice job by grisham going first to third
on the base hit to left center field
eric hussmer leading off for the san
diego padres
that's a beauty strike three called
hosmer down looking
one away that's the front door two
seamer eric osborne knew it not a lot
you can do with that pitch but it's
located as well as lancelin located this
one connor falefa
has grounded out to short and reach on
an arrow then connor falefa strikes out
got away from hedges briefly so he tags
him
first strikeout for stamin out number
two with the seventh so with 107 pitches
lynn's going to face taunties for a
fourth time
little comebacker again lim doing it all
himself in this seventh inning takes
care of tatis a one two three for the
bulldog
that is strike three over the inside
edge too santana
he doesn't like it at all he says some
stuff to home plate umpire alfonso mark
has more stuff
yeah that's off the plate that's a ball
gallow
will lead things off he comes
[Applause]
this one
hit well
deep out to right
back to the wall gone
joey gallo is tied at the ninth with a
solo home run
and the padres have them loaded and a
chance here for manny machado
machado at a deep left field it is high
deep in it is a grand slam to walk it
off manny batano is tonight's padres
hero